Прихід до України німецького Flixbus, гіганта автобусних перевезень у Європі,
викликало сподівання, що ціни на міжнародні поїздки
автобусами для українців зменшаться.
Та на швидкі зміни цінової політики у цій галузі
розраховувати не варто, попереджають експерти.
По-перше, Flixbus ще торік продавав квитки на рейси
зі Львова та Ужгорода до Амстердама, Берліна, Відня та інших міст.
Але де-факто перевезення здійснювала інша компанія - Leo Express.
Це звична практика для великих європейських компаній,
які намагаються не ризикувати на старті
і співпрацють спершу з регіональними партнерами.
Приміром, за новими маршрутами  Flixbus,
що стартувати наприкінці липня,
- з Києва, Львова, Рівного та Житомира до Польщі та Чехії -
перевезення здійснюватимуть автобуси чеської компанії Umbrella, а не "Flixbus".
По-друге, це не нові напрямки.
За даними  Держслужби України з безпеки на транспорті,
нині на українському ринку налічується загалом понад три тисячі міжнародних маршрутів
до 46 країн світу. І чимало з них - саме до Польщі та Чехії.
До того ж, завдяки скасуванню віз з Євросоюзом
частка міжнародних автобусних перевезеннь і далі зростатиме -
за прогнозами експертів, на 20-30%.
По-третє, на відміну від авіаперевезень,
в Україні досить жорстка конкуренція між автобусними перевізниками.
За інформацією Мінінфраструктури,
ліцензії на міжнародні перевезення  мають понад три з половиною тисячі перевізників.
Причому левова частка пасажирських автобусів,
що перетинають кордон в напрямку Європи - близько 80 відсотків -
це автобуси з українською реєстрацією.
По-четверте, Flixbus - далеко не перша велика міжнародна автобусна компанія,
що виходить на український ринок.
Раніше це вже зробили польська PolskiBUs,
латвійська ECOLINES та чеська Leo Express.
І це майже не вплинуло на ціни.
І по-п'яте - ціни Flixbus
плюс-мінус такі ж, як у конкурентів.
Наприклад, квитки зі Львова до Праги або Кракова
коштують близько семисот гривень.
Ціни вітчизняних перевізників на ці напрямки - майже стільки ж.
Тим не менше, прихід Flixbus в Україну безперечно є плюсом.
Це підвищує здорову конкуренцію.
Автобуси німецької компанії, приміром, набагато зручніші і комфортніші, ніж українські.
Тож, у перспективі це може вплинути
на поліпшення сервісу й українських перевізників.